[Music]
matthew's with us in tulsa oklahoma hi
matthew how are you
great how are you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
um i've just got kind of a career
question um but i was going to give you
a rundown of myself and my wife's
financials first
i make we're both self-employed
no debt other than our home
i make about 120 she makes about 60.
we owe 160 on our home it's worth about
3 305
and i actually sell real estate really
looking forward to the reality check
and i'm just curious should i take the
chance because i have an opportunity to
start my own brokerage but should i take
that chance with a baby on the way with
all the risks that we know come with
starting your own company
so you're a real estate broker now i'm
making 120 000 a year
i'm an agent yes
yeah i'm getting my license shortly yes
okay how long have you been selling real
estate
a little over a year
okay i'm 22 my wife's 22 also okay
i was doing the same thing you're doing
when i was your age
um
and i got my real estate license when i
was 18.
okay so
i know what you're facing one of the
things you're facing is it's tough to
have credibility with people to sell
them houses when you're only 22 right
yeah you got an uphill battle there and
having your own brokerage would probably
help with that a little
or it might scare or it might scare them
even more
well see i feel like i don't have as
much of a problem with customers as i
would with people working under me
because i've been doing it 20 years and
think about how young you are right from
like a leadership perspective someone
respected right yeah
and just with a kid doing october it's
like do we take this chance when we're
sitting pretty good right now yeah and
we've got a real estate market that is
um twisting and turning in the wind
it's uh it's very unpredictable right
now
i mean i i
i think the market's going to slow down
i don't think house prices are going to
go down we've already said that out loud
but i think it's going to slow down
so yeah my only concern would be matthew
you got into the real estate business
in the best time ever so like what you
made then
not saying you can't make that again by
any means but it was probably easier to
make what you made then then it's going
to be easier to make that same amount in
the next coming years because of the
slowing and softening of the market so
what's your wife say
she says do it because it's a it's a
pretty good option i mean it's a pretty
good opportunity with a business partner
who has a very good end
i'm sorry a business partner
that's a new part that's new information
yeah i would be opening it with a with a
partner
no don't do that
oh really no
you're already married
yeah
all right listen the only ship on sale
is a partnership
the number of business small business
partnerships that survive one decade is
very close to zero
almost none of them do we work with
entre leadership businesses tens of
thousands of them and have for decades
all across america and one of the
biggest problems they have is a stinking
partnership it's gone sideways
now the exception is medical
partnerships and law partnerships but
they're structured differently anyway
it's a whole different setup but two
guys opening a real estate company two
guys opening up a uh heat and air
company two women open up a nail salon
this is just a it's just a no
no
no
no no you don't you don't need a partner
uh okay so what i what i'm gonna tell
you is is scary for me to tell you
because i believe in getting after it
when you're young and you're an
ambitious and smart young guy and i hate
to tell you not to do something but
while you get
another 18 months is going to give you a
lot of information about life a lot of
perspective especially if it's your
first baby too there's just a lot of
changes let the baby get born let's get
past some of this rough patch in the
real estate let's see what's going on
you save up you open up with your money
doesn't cost that much to open up a
brokerage firm if you open it up when
you're 25 instead of your 22 you're
gonna be just fine
and low patience yeah i think it's gonna
be good for you